connaissez-vous la draft NBA c'est notre
credo ici à envergure et nous allons
vous présenter notre épisode qui
reviendra sur le mois de mars ça
s'appelle Victor et les autres parce que
figurez-vous que cette année dans la
draft et ben il y a Victor
le père et met Hugo il prennent en main
Victor se fils dont le destin d'effraya
les gazettes au menu aujourd'hui dans la
première partie on dira quelques mots de
mois de mars de Victor one bagnama qui a
été très productif pour le coup avec les
Metz de Boulogne Levallois et puis on
aura une grosse page sur la marshmallet
et sur les prospects qui se sont montrés
ce qui se sont un peu cachés et ceux qui
se sont montrés sous un mauvais jour
donc on vous dira ça permettra aussi de
parler de nouvelles têtes à l'approche
de la draft puisque dans les un peu plus
d'un mois on aura la loterie NBA et dans
deux mois et 10 jours et ben on
enregistre le 10 avril et bien dans deux
mois et 10 jours ce sera déjà la draft
2023 pour m'accompagner nous avons el
Manou Manu comment vas-tu ça va et vous
et toi
et ouais tu peux me tutoyer ça va bien
et Hugues de l'autre côté
salut à tous j'espère que vous allez
bien
on va tous bien je crois le printemps
arrive et nous allons parler
marshmadness mais d'abord partie 1 web
baniyama son mois de mars c'est parti
sur les derniers matchs que tu as vu
est-ce que tu as
des observations sur sur sa production
qui est
il a fait un bon mois il était nommé
pour être joueur du mois d'ailleurs
comme tous les mois donc ça c'est pas
c'est pas du nouveau moi je stabilise le
match du manque où ils ont joué le 23
donc ça fait le Mans Monaco et
Strasbourg et de victoire une défaite et
il a fait du Victor mais il a été très
très fort dans le scoring avec un match
à 26 et 29 un peu plus en deçà contre
Monaco il fait que 8 points
les super important autre part notamment
rebond il en prend 14 un peu plus de
passe aussi donc ça c'est super
intéressant de le voir là dessus trois
contre Monaco il sera pas 7 à on s'en
fiche mais c'est super intéressant de le
voir un peu plus
une volve dans le j'ai perdu le mot
français dans le dans la
impliqué
donc c'est super intéressant après il a
fait du il a fait du Victor quoi il y a
pas de rendez-vous sur
ces sur ces matchs pour moi en tout cas
où j'ai beaucoup plus appris sur le sur
l'équipe de France quand il était avec
l'équipe de France que là en ce moment
avait en Belgique
qu'est-ce que tu avais appris en équipe
de France parce que du coup on s'était
pas une n'avait pas eu ton retour
l'opportunité d'aller le voir quand ils
ont joué la Lituanie à Angers
et j'avais vu aussi les matchs
précédents
à la télé ou je l'ai vu j'ai retrouvé le
Wayne bagnaba d'avant en fait où il
était un peu plus
parce scolaire mais un peu plus
attentiste notamment en défense où on a
retrouvé ce temps de latence qu'il a
qu'il avait plutôt quand il était un peu
plus jeune
du coup ça y compenser ça par sa
longueur à chaque fois il était souvent
en retard sur sur sa prise de décision
il avait tout à ce petit temps de
latence du coup retard il se prenait
toujours au moins il y avait une
tentative de de panier qui avait souvent
des points à l'arrivée aussi
et une capacité enfin la non capacité
aussi à
ne pas trop savoir contenir les les
bigmens en face où on a le il y a une
image qui a fait un peu le tour des
internets c'est quand il se fait dunker
dessus par le en Bosnie
où il se fait il se fait mal traquer au
poste et il arrive pas à contenir donc
ça c'est encore ces deux choses là pour
moi
j'en attends un peu plus l'année
prochaine pas cette année parce que ça
qui le changera cette année peut-être
s'il va la Coupe du monde à voir
mais voilà c'est vraiment ces deux
points là moi où je où j'attends encore
un peu plus sur les années à venir
est-ce que la manière de cheat Holmes
graines l'année dernière même si Victor
paraît un poil plus costaud en tout cas
il a eu le temps de faire peut-être plus
de muscu mais est-ce que
comme Shetland ça serait bien qui est
un mec avec un centre de gravité plus
bas à côté de lui dans l'équipe et qui
peut se taper justement les gros les
gros Bosniens les zubats les qui
viennent qui viennent enfoncer quoi les
vallons de suunas etc pas en équipe
possible après il y a le sur les équipes
là actuellement qui qui sont lisses pour
le pour la loterie il y a pas forcément
ce joueur de ce genre de joueur enfin là
je le vois pas en tout cas
si tu vas au piston tu vas voir
Washington si tu vas Charlotte tu vas
avoir Jackson si tu vas Indiana et puis
de l'autre côté les comme d'habitude
donc tu vas tu vas avoir de la taille
il va il va franchement il fait une
bonne année ça sera un autre débat mais
il fait une bonne année
surtout sur la fin mais je le vois pas
défendre sur les cinq en fait l'année
prochaine enfin sur les gros babacs dont
on parle
alors après c'est toujours pareil les
cinq ils sont là en saison régulière en
playoff il joue 10 à 15 minutes après
peut-être que sur la justement cette
année où je sais pas sur laquelle il va
tomber il va pas peut-être pas forcément
jouer dans une équipe pour les petits
jours à les PLF donc ce sera peut-être
aussi l'occasion pour le s'épaissir un
peu sans trop charger la mule mais voilà
et d'apprendre justement à rejouer avec
le bas et le haut du corps voilà à tout
bien enclenché pour que ça devienne
en défenseur NBA plus que correct dans
cette zone du jeu en tout cas
dans ce que tu as noté c'est intéressant
le rebond parce que alors ça reste des
stats brut mais pour le coup le rebond
c'est une des stats tous les stades
bruts
le plus parlant quand même s'il y a le
dirait il y a des joueurs qui box ça et
qui prennent pas de rebond c'est confère
Brooke Lopez mais
il a 5 matchs de suite à plus de dire
bon
Victor donc c'est quand même intéressant
dans dans le rôle qui va avoir
défensivement sur cette fin de saison
c'est ce qui est un petit peu dommage
c'est que très bonne Twitter
ne va plus jouer et à la fois en fait à
la fois je trouve ça dommage et à la
fois je me dis peut-être que du coup ça
va amener Victor à avoir d'autres
responsabilités et de toute façon en
fait on a l'impression de le connaître
tellement bien que tout nouveau rôle est
un petit peu excitant en tout cas en
perspective de ce côté donc
on verra comment ça se passe sur la fin
de saison régulière et puis les phases
finales de Betclic élite en tout cas il
y a une chose que j'ai notée qui est
intéressante et je voulais te faire
réagir là dessus Manu et peut-être
Hugues aussi
tu parlais de s'épaissir je pense qu'il
travaille beaucoup et même c'est sûr
enfin de match il y a Thomas Dufont de
la First steam qui va l'interviewer je
sais plus quel match c'est mais c'est un
match où il a bien rentré ses tirs et
Thomas lui dit bon j'écoute j'ai
l'impression que
tu as bien retrouvé ton tir tu t'es
retrouvé aujourd'hui et Victor répond
ouais bah en fait je fais tellement de
muscu que j'ai même pas le temps de
travailler mon tir et juste là cette
semaine on s'y remis un peu et c'est
tombé dedans quoi vu que tu dis que
c'était contre le ment après Le Mans
ouais je crois c'est le dernier match je
vois la force steam commenter où il
prend des des gros tirs à trois points
en transition etc donc je vois bien le
Mans c'est un match très impressionnant
d'ailleurs
le dernier à domicile c'est sur le bon
ouais c'est ça
et du coup
est-ce qu'on n'est pas un peu je vois je
vois de temps en temps alors c'est à la
marge mais je vois de temps en temps des
des internautes qui qui se contentent
surtout des stats et qui vont et ce qui
est vrai que sur les les mois depuis les
mois janvier février victoire un peu
moins à droite depuis le début de saison
où il est en pleine fanfare il est un
peu moins à droite et qui disent ouais
est-ce qu'en fait c'est vraiment alors
on fera un focus sur son tir au prochain
podcast un gros focus sur le tir de
Victor mais
est-ce qu'on n'est pas un peu trop dur
dans le jugement de la progression
technique en fait de Victor parce qu'il
a tellement besoin de faire de muscu que
peut-être qu'il a pas le temps de bosser
certains aspects qu'il aimerait bosser
après c'est pas de la muscu comme on
l'entend c'est pas les LaSalle et
soulever sans 130 kg en développer
couché mais non c'est plus en bas du
corps je pense de toute façon on l'a
bien vu déjà sur cette année où il a un
peu épaissi tu vois qu'il a changé
physiquement en tout cas et toi il en a
besoin comme tous les joueurs qui qui
vont traverser l'Atlantique donc
peut-être qu'il laisse un peu ça
traverse mais comme tu dis après tu as
les gens lambda et il y a nous entre
guillemets sans faire de généralité ou
auxoires trop beau mais on va nous
finalement qu'il en marque 76 ou qu'il
en marque 4
moi ça va pas me je sais ce qui sait
faire je m'attends pas à ce qui domine
ce qu'il le fait déjà donc moi ça me ça
fait un avis dit un moment quoi ouais
aussi et puis maintenant ce qui va ce
qui va être jugé c'est son hors terrain
c'est plus tard
parce que le terrain il est toute la
saison donc et sur ça pour le coup il y
a pas de enfin pas de retour négatif
pour le moment bien sûr on n'est pas au
quotidien avec lui vu que tu avais un
truc à dire sur la muscu physique parce
que je trouve ça quand même
vraiment impressionnant sur toute
l'année
là vous aviez interviewé Massa le pivot
de Strasbourg il a passé longtemps parce
qu'il avait fait un grand match voilà
j'ai vu le dernier match on se revoit tu
vois qu'il a appris quand même il y a
des prises de position au poste bas avec
des retournés où il finit le bras par
dessus athlétiquement c'est très solide
et physiquement il y a plus d'impact
aussi donc moi j'ai vraiment été très
impressionné par cette par cette prise
de masse cette prise d'intensité dans
l'impact tout au long de la saison et
c'est peut-être aussi lié et la toujours
ma faiblesse mais au fait que bah ça y
est il a atteint ça cette croissance il
est il grandira pas beaucoup plus que ça
ils ont enfin pu l'épaissir et donc on
commence à voir vraiment le le prospect
physique NBA athletic on va attendre tu
parler de tchat était tout fin mais tu
étais très puissant Chatti bougez pas on
avait vu peut-être qui prenait des
contacts etc face à dylene duwen j'aime
bien se mettre sur référence je tenais
Victor il était plus en deçà à reculons
plus dans le slip dans la périphérie là
je commence à avoir un vrai joueur où je
me dis ok même de l'an prochain il va
pouvoir il va pouvoir être sur le
terrain il va pouvoir encaisser et il va
pouvoir se développer sans un risque de
blessure trop rapide donc
si vous avez pas vu Victor cette année
parce que vous avez dit bon bah c'est
bon je le connais j'en ai Ras-le qui ça
fait 5 ans qu'on le voit tous les jours
regardez physiquement le le la prise de
masse est impressionnante il faudra
faire un avant après peut-être pour
en ce qui concerne les photos ce serait
sans doute intéressant est-ce que une
dernière question sur Victor est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous attendez de cette fin
de saison régulière et puis des playoffs
en fait de Betclic élite c'est-à-dire
tout ce qui va se passer près draft
est-ce que vous attendez quelque chose
moi justement ça va être son son impact
et son attitude en playoff est-ce qu'il
va Step Up est vraiment se montrer
encore plus leader qui ne l'est déjà que
ce soit sur le en dehors du terrain sur
les entraînements sur le banc et en
match c'est vraiment ça que je vais
attendre mon là c'est un peu plus du
détail du coup mais comme offensivement
à défensivement en terme de jeu pour moi
Stany frappe pas grand chose de plus
donc c'est vraiment plus sur ça le
leader ship
il y a des phases de jeu que peut-être
tu aimerais voir et qu'on voit plus en
phase finale qu'en phase régulière
parce que c'est un truc que j'aime
beaucoup chez lui moi c'est sur les
petites passes la réactivité
parce qu'il va être plus en plus frappé
il va de plus en plus être agressé voir
comment il ressort le ballon et ces
dernières semaines j'ai vu des très
belles lectures des kick à l'opposé
l'espace de relance qu'on avait déjà vu
mais voilà voir comment il s'adapte à
façon adversité où on va se concentrer
sur lui et pour l'instant il réagit bien
donc j'espère avoir plus de ça mais je
suis pas je suis pas un cas là-dessus
c'est très intéressant effectivement à
observer si vous voulez observer que
Victor sur un match le timing c'est à
dire que parfois la prise à deux elle
vient mais on attend quand même une
seconde pour que le coéquipier soit dans
la bonne fenêtre ou pour que la défense
soit un peu plus déstabilisée et parfois
au contraire faut anticiper c'est très
intéressant à observer et de toute façon
les grands joueurs les grands superstars
NBA elle est elle les ont elles se
timing
c'est ses capacités à lire la défense et
à anticiper les mouvements de la défense
donc ça va être intéressant de voir
torsader à ça même si il doit déjà le
faire comme Hugo disait
on a fini sur lui on va passer à la
deuxième partie on va passer aux autres
et à la à ce bilan ma douce
ur et
[Musique]
et oui c'est Yukon qui a gagné la marche
Mendes Hugh est content parce que c'est
une équipe qui joue bien au basket non
mais c'est vrai pour le coup
enfin il y a pas beaucoup de monde
c'était une marche manette avec plein de
surprises il y avait pas de Cid 1 au
final fort
c'était c'était assez surprenant mais
Yukon a vraiment roulé sur toute la
compétition ils ont explosé tout le
monde en gros et c'est ils ont très peu
douté l'équipe qui les a fait le plus
douter c'est peut-être sainte Maryse
jusqu'à ce qu'elle aurait lieu qui se
blesse mais sinon sinon c'était c'était
plutôt une pas une promenade de santé
parce que ça l'est jamais mais c'était
plutôt
une belle domination pour l'équipe du
Connecticut qui a en son sein x prospect
NBA x parce qu'on sait pas le nombre
qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé je
commence avec celui qui est le plus haut
sur notre big board et et qu'est-ce que
ça va lui apporter et qu'est-ce que vous
avez pensé il faudra le présenter aussi
de Jordan Hawkins messieurs
je me permets je me permets parce que
parce que Jordan
[Musique]
hawkinsvergure vous savez que je l'avais
déjà l'autre il en dernier c'était un
jour que moi j'aimais beaucoup qui était
en sortie de band derrière des mecs
expérimentés comme star is Burton qui
ont tout way en NBA ou air Jackal le
meneur qui a je crois qu'ils vont au
dillig et peut-être qu'ils passent en
Europe donc c'est un joueur qui avait
assez peu de répétitions avec un coach
qui fait jouer les plus vieux d'analyse
et qui avait pris feu lors du tournoi
battle for Atlantis le tournoi où ils
avaient joué au burn Michigan State etc
et j'avais vu un joueur qui qui était un
pyromane qui était un petit roman en
puissance qui est monté fin 1m96 je
crois qu'il fait 85 kg une belle
envergure
et qui c'est un poste de pour donner le
poste 2 il va jouer deux trois NBA mais
pour l'instant il est fin donc il va
surtout défendre les postes de essayer
de défendre parce que il y a les outils
athlétiques mais il manque encore de
d'épaisseur physique et il a fait cette
année un rôle vraiment de joueur de
catch and shoot alors plusieurs types de
catch and shoot un jour qui sort tout le
temps des écrans qui courent tout le
temps qui courent partout qui s'arrête
jamais qui se retourne très vite qui
gagne à la vitesse à la distance NBA qui
dégaine très rapidement capable de se
réhaxer qui va souvent chercher le
contact sur cette tirs c'est un joueur
il a le tir de Jamal coiffeur le tir à 4
points 3 1 3 points plus la faute et en
fait souvent tomber et qui est
inconscient le truc c'est qu'il a fait
une Marthe Madness où il s'est jamais
calmé il a des fois laissé le jeu venir
à lui sur une première mi-temps où il
prenait peu de tir et puis deuxième
mi-temps il en prend 8 d'affilée tout ce
contester et mets les 8 donc tu peux
rien faire
ça va lui donner effectivement une très
belle valeur au niveau de sa draft parce
qu'on a une projection directe en NBA
joueur qui va donner du spacing genre
qui va pouvoir créer du mouvement qui va
pouvoir créer de la gravité l'erreur
peut être à ne pas faire c'est de en
gros de se dire que ce mec-là va tourner
à 70% à 3 points tout le temps et il y a
un vrai développement physique à mettre
en place qui a pas été fait en deux ans
yucon du coup sophomore pour espérer un
peu plus parce que top 10 espère quand
même un peu de création Ball en main moi
j'y crois parce que c'est un jour qui
crée des écarts qui est très fort pour
pour se créer son propre tir mais qui
pour le moment explosent un peu près du
panier et qui ressemble un peu à ce que
James booknight faisait à Yukon dans le
même dans le même style de jeu et il
tient on voit que booknight en moins de
jussie peut-être quand même ah je vais
du jus franchement
verticalement je parle ouais parce que
en triple le saut il serait il serait
compétiteur olympique alors tu as le
droit qu'à deux pas en NBA mais
normalement mais
il se projette très vite vers à l'avant
en juin hand of il peut vraiment partir
de la ligne à trois points au panier sur
un double pas c'est vraiment
impressionnant et par contre faut
prendre de la masse physique voilà moi
je suis très amoureux du joueur
mais je l'avais loterie l'an dernier je
l'ai toujours loterie top 10 fin de mon
top 10 et je suis très content pour lui
belle mars Madness pour lui même s'il a
eu connu des matchs en plus c'était pas
facile où il avait des problèmes de
fautes etc il avait c'est compliqué là
NCA tu as le droit qu'à 5 fautes et du
coup ton coach si tu as deux fautes en
première mi-temps en 4 minutes tu peux
passer 16 minutes sur leboncoin
petite rivière il a une intoxication
alimentaire juste avant le final Faure
il a bouffée du calamar et il a dit je
ne mangerai plus jamais du calamar de ma
vie donc il te fait un une demi-finale
où il a vraiment complètement mal au
vide et on le voit en première mi-temps
il est pas bien et en deuxième mi-temps
bah il fait du Jordan il prend chaud il
s'hydrate un petit peu et puis il a fini
il a fini la soirée en PLS il avait été
isolé de ses coéquipiers au cas où ils
craignent une gastro mais non c'était
c'était du calamar le responsable le
calamar game Jordan avait son flou game
Manu qu'est-ce que tu as qu'est-ce que
tu as à dire sur notre ami Hawkins
qu'est-ce que tu as vu et qu'est-ce
qu'il y a pu plaire aux observateurs sur
sur cette marche
ce que moi je me plaît et que je pense
qu'il plaît à tout le les contingents
NBA c'est son tir il est juste
incroyable tir il a une diversité de
dire qui est assez folle et moi ce que
je vais attendre ce qu'on a un peu vu je
trouve sur sur le tournoi c'est de la
c'est sa création donc moi je vais
attendre qu'il arrive à créer encore un
peu plus pour lui mais surtout qu'il
arrive à créer pour les autres moi mon
mon
ma comparaison parfaite pour lui c'est
déjà mal Murray
qui deviennent
surtout dans la création pour les heures
en fait j'avais le Murray était à peu
près pareil avec Kentucky était beaucoup
plus axé sur le tir parce que John
Calais Paris savait pas s'en servir
mais il est devenu assez incroyable à
Denver et moi j'attends un peu cette
même trajectoire d'un joueur comme qui
font plus ou moins la même taille je
crois ils sont assez xxx
et qu'il arrive à porter la balle un peu
plus constamment et qu'il arrive à la
développer du jeu en fait pour pas que
ce soit juste un joueur qui fasse du tir
et qui deviennent une sorte de un peu
comme on voit en ce moment comme Thomas
quoi qui qui en abuse
qui en habit qu'est-ce que tu entends
par diversité de tir pour ceux qui nous
écoutent bah si tu es capable de cacher
une shoot de shooter end of de shooter
après son dribble de shooter après écran
de shooter partout
de shooter c'est vraiment ça ouais qui
peut tirer passe il faut il a pas besoin
d'une seule position que ce soit par
exemple du catchu de corner et qui
savent faire que ça là c'est vraiment
une diversité un peu partout et ça c'est
super et il est pas juste non plus
obligé de prendre du catching shoot il
peut aller en dribble faire un pas tir
s'élever tout de suite
faire un peu plus juste prendre l'écran
et s'élever tout seul c'est c'est super
intéressant c'est ce qu'on recherche
maintenant une miel et des joueurs comme
ça capable de d'évoluer quoi que ce soit
sur du bas du pic justement le pic and
roll comme ça PAF tout de suite il fera
pas du pop parce qu'il a pas encore le
physique et il a pas la taille mais
voilà c'est ouais nous diversité ce qui
shootait de partout et de différentes
manières
et il prend des shoots difficiles il
prend des shoots difficiles parce que si
tu regardes les pourcentages tu te dis
c'est un bon shooter ouais cette virgule
site tentative par match
38%, c'est un bon shooter mais c'est un
shooter il y en a d'autres non je pense
pas qu'il y en a d'autres dans le dans
le haut de la draft des shooters comme
ça c'était
le système de Yukon était basé pas basé
mais quand il était sur le terrain c'est
Jordan Hawkins va faire 15 secondes de
sprint autour d'écran un peu à la
ripamilton époque des trois quoi et
capable de stopper boom monter
directement et de toute façon ce
mouvement de Jordan Hawkins va créer des
espaces et ça c'est une plus-value qui
est tellement facile à voir en NBA parce
que tu fais exactement la même chose et
ton
et ton équipe va avoir des opportunités
le mop du final force n'est pas Jordan
Hawkins c'est notre ami Sanogo
l'intérieur de cette équipe de
Connecticut alors Manu est-ce que tu
vois un avenir
NBA ou plutôt un avenir Europe ou plutôt
autre chose pour pour Sanogo qui est en
intérieur je vais je vais peut-être le
présenter rapidos mais c'est un
intérieur qui a une petite diversité
même si il était surtout utilisé comme
comme finisseur il est quand même
capable de il y a une petite patate
assez sympa avec avec un très bon 76%
relancé France cette année il a 2 mètres
6 puis il fait un bon taille poids quoi
belle bête de mettre 600 8 kg
bien solide bien solide ouais dans la
peinture il monte assez facilement il a
dû il a du Jump il est assez explosif
mais effectivement capable alors à
faible dose mais 36% à 3 points sur 1,3
tentative et c'est nouveau il a ajouté
cette corde à son arc cette année
pas un extraordinaire protecteur de
cercle
mais c'était pas nécessairement tout le
temps son travail dans cette équipe
et voilà un joueur qui est en troisième
année j'ai oublié de dire je sais plus
de quelle année il est c'est en 2001
je sais plus 2002 c'est un 2002 comment
ok c'est en 2002 comme Jordan au kinds
Manu est-ce qu'il y a un avenir pour lui
dans la grande ligue après avoir été mop
du final Faure comme l'était à l'époque
donte divine chanzo
pour moi non il y a trop de trop de
lacunes dans le jeu en fait c'est un
joueur NSIA parfait tout simplement il
s'est développé en supérieur NCA et il
va dire il reste en plus je crois cette
année il reste une saison entier je
crois pas qu'il va la draft il va
transfère
on avait vu ça genre presque 2 millions
donc il aura un meilleur contrat quand
NBA
ouais non moi je suis pas je suis pas
des joueurs dont je suis fan en fait
c'est vraiment du
pour moi c'est un pivot lambda en fait
ok il a un peu ajouté de tir cette année
mais c'est pas
c'est pas le joueur que je regardais en
fait à yougon qui me sautait au jeu
comme ça c'est en ouais c'est un Bigo
ouais mais tu vois c'est ce type de
joueur qui pour moi est limité en fait
il y a pas beaucoup de plus-value en NBA
même dans le jeu il est ultra limité
quoi c'est à dire limité bah faut qu'il
soit à 3 mètres du panier autrement il
voit flou
ça c'est pas vrai ça
c'est pas des sujets c'est pas des
joueurs qui me moi qui m'attire et que
j'aime regarder en fait c'est plus c'est
plus ça c'est plutôt l'opinion perso
mais je le venant je le vois pas une
bière que ce soit là maintenant ou dans
5 ans
ce que tu penses pareil alors je le vois
pas une billet non plus mais pas pour
les mêmes raisons moi le problème que
j'ai avec Adama Sanogo c'est qu'il fait
de mettre 06 et que c'est pas une bête
verticale non plus c'est pas voilà il
peut monter aux dingue mais c'est pas un
gars qui a un athlète au niveau NBA
après il donne un peu de spacing à dire
qu'il faut vraiment pied au béton mais
qui donne un peu de tir il pose très
bien le ballon en fait c'est ça qui
était impressionnant en année 2 et qu'on
a un peu moins vu cette année c'est que
il dribble très bien pour aller jusqu'au
panier genre du choix sur du depuis la
ligne des lancé François sur du sur
troll mais c'est pas une projection
qu'on va faire parce qu'une équipe NBA
ne va pas acheter un mec de 2 m 06 qui
est pas un rebondeur élite qui est pas
un protecteur de cercle élite pour un
peu de spécing donc je pense qu'il va
taper des années Angelique et puis
derrière par contre j'aimerais bien le
voir en Europe donc vrai joueur
universitaire c'est vrai je suis
d'accord avec Manu vraie pivot dominant
à ce niveau là mais je crois pas une
projection parce que juste là la valeur
marchande du joueur est par chercher
actuellement quoi elle est très très
basse oui et peut-être que en vraiment
développant ce jeu de 4 un peu costaud
etc c'est peut être un profil qui peut
intéresser en Neuroligue en tout cas en
Coupe d'Europe du côté du côté du Vieux
Continent le plafond ce serait un Xavier
Tilman et une
deux un NBA et Xavier Tilman était
meilleur défensivement dans le placement
dans le rebond
c'est des des stats au bloc et hostile
ce qui sont qui sont assez
impressionnantes par rapport à la taille
qui qui fait effectivement des grosses
paluches de Xavier même si Sanogo il
donne pas sa parole chien en termes de
grande main je crois
Hugues je te laisse présenter parler de
de troisième joueur de Yukon qui coûte
potentiellement
à marquer des points et lui peut-être
qu'il va se présenter à la draft pour le
coup contrairement
pour l'instant on n'a pas de news je
serai assez surpris qu'il n'y aille pas
l'an dernier déjà il avait un peu testé
les os et puis il était revenu André
Jackson pour présenter c'est
quoi c'est un ailier c'est un
engrenage d'un mètre 80 16 98 très
athlétique avec alors une coupe afro qui
fait monter le centimètre mais très très
athlétique qui jouait meneur en High
School qui l'an dernier était vraiment
l'ailier qui que t'ai qui donne quai il
faisait que ça parce qu'il y avait des
mecs qui avaient le ballon en main et
cette année c'est partagé la gouffe avec
twist on Newton l'ancien meneur
d'iskarolina donc ils se sont partagés
le jeu à deux c'est beaucoup de Ré
Jackson qui m'était en place le le
basket notamment sur de la sur de la
transition il récupère le rebond parce
qu'il monte très haut toujours très bien
placé il remonte la balle et ensuite il
passe vraiment bien
on a cette image en tête moi toute
l'année la dépasse où il remonte il
court en transition et puis juste il
pose la balle derrière lui parce que tu
as Jordan Hawkins dans le trailer qui
prend un tir à trois points à 19 mètres
donc voilà le niveau du profil
un ailier qui défend extrêmement bien
qui est toujours placé sur le meilleur
porteur de baladverses très athlétique
qui pose des écrans qui va dans le cut
qui finit bien au panier mais qui a pas
de tir c'est quand même le gros défaut
faut être honnête il a il a pas de tir à
trois points 29% je crois dans
l'efficacité peut-être un peu moins
petit volume
une mécanique absolument
ignoble il en a pris quelques-uns
lorsque les défenses elles passent sous
les écrans tellement il est mauvais il
les a un peu forcément il en a très peu
mis donc voilà dans la projection
vraiment on est sur les les profils à là
moi j'aime bien les Blues Brown juniors
les mecs comme ça
qui connecte tout pour moi ce sera ça
c'est un très bon connecteur NBA qui
défendra très très bien qui fera des
écrans qui couperaient etc mais qui
pourrait être ciblés et être une comment
dire être négatif dans le spacing donc
des mecs comme ça NBA très peu
on les achète souvent pas cher moi je
vais l'avoir entre 20 et 30 parce que je
crois en la maturité du joueur dans son
pour bonifier un bon collectif
l'exemple facile c'est Denver par
exemple certains tout le temps
la réalité des choses je pense que ce
sera un mec qui sera si valable draft
second tour voir un draftted parce que
maintenant il faut avoir du spacing mais
qui sera toujours bon là où il joue
Manu est-ce que tu as des choses à
ajouter sur André est-ce que tu l'as tu
l'as peut-être tu as peut-être trouvé
qu'il avait fait qui est marqué des
points dans cette marche manette
moi je trouve le profil super
intéressant en fait de il est capable de
faire ce qu'il sait faire il le fait
plutôt bien justement de tir donc c'est
vrai que c'est un peu un peu dommage de
shooter 28% et même 64 % c'est français
assez dégueulasse pendant un Élie
arrière donc c'est vraiment ça qui pêche
parce que c'est de la création pour les
autres c'est un connecteur c'est
l'activité défensive que moi je trouve
plutôt intéressant quand même
donc c'est c'est un peu dommage après
le shoot ça se travaille c'est l'une des
choses les plus simples entre guillemets
à travailler surtout avec un staff NBA
donc peut-être un second tour
effectivement après c'est c'est un
contexte qu'il faut il faut qu'il soit
parfait s'il est pas parfait c'est
foutu là c'est vrai que second tour
c'est un pari comme dit qui coûte pas
cher c'est un mec si tu arrives à le
faire shooter à 32 %
dont 36 dans les corners qui shoots
peut-être quand il soit ouvert en fait
déjà ce serait une belle pointe faire
que du catch and shout grand ouvert mais
bon après on playoff ça devient
compliqué quoi et puis même en saison en
fin de saison régulière quand c'est
serré
je donnais l'exemple la dernière fois
quand on discutait en privé mais quand
on voit comme les défendu air Jones
aujourd'hui il est plus du tout respecté
par par les défenses adverses et ça pose
des gros problèmes quand même aux
spacing des pellicans donc
c'est assez compliqué après si tu tombes
comme tu disais dans le bon contexte
avec un intérieur en fait qui est un
gros shooter etc et que tu peux te
permettre d'être le seul nom shooter de
du 5
dans ce cas là ça peut faire mais ça
veut dire qu'il faut apporter énormément
de l'autre côté pour pour avoir cette
cette valeur d'être placée sur le
terrain
on parle pas de Joey
qui je pense pas sera joueur NBA même si
bon on sait jamais mais c'est un sniper
en arrière l'arrière remplaçant qui qui
venait pour mettre le feu qui rentrait
pour mettre le feu 6e de cette équipe de
Yukon c'était assez sympa avoir joué
grosse énergie
mais voilà on va pas on va pas passer
des minutes là dessus à la place je vous
ai demandé de choisir chacun deux
joueurs
qui vous ont positivement surpris ou en
tout cas qui ont confirmé la bonne
opinion que vous avez liée d'eux et de
joueurs à l'inverse qui qui vous ont
déçus ou qui ont déçus ou qui ou qui
n'ont pas confirmé ce que vous espériez
on commence par Manu et on commence par
les déceptions finira par les bonnes
nouvelles la première c'est qui ma
première déception c'est Nick Smith
d'Arkansas
qui est quand même très haut sur notre
big board je suis en train de vérifier
[Musique]
c'est en fait il a ça marche pas naisses
il a confirmé ce que j'ai pas aimé de
lui donc c'est c'est un joueur qui va
avoir du mal à terminer aussi
pas dedans bah il est quasiment
inexistant en fait il a plus d'impact du
tout pour son équipe donc c'est assez
dommage et c'est ce qui s'est passé sur
sa saison en fait où il y a eu quelques
quelques flashs quelques
gros matchs à plus de 20 points mais
c'est assez limité finalement et il a
pas réussi à
apprendre la mesure de son talent en
fait ou par rapport il a pas su non plus
profiter du manque d'adresse de Brandon
Miller
voilà il a pas montré il a même fait
pire que sa saison je trouve et il a mis
en évidence ses points faibles donc
c'est je pense qu'il va descendre
oui il va glisser un peu à la draft mais
après il y a toujours ce profil de
scorer dont on parlait en précédent qui
est intéressant
High School ou il était juste formidable
sur peut-être sur le la gêne ce qui peut
aussi être un point faible c'est sur sa
blessure ses blessures au genou
est-ce que c'est est-ce que ça l'a gêné
et du coup bah c'est performances sont
ressenti ou est-ce que il est vraiment
dans le mal et que voilà la blessure
reviendra un jour ou l'autre
ça c'est c'est au médecin et au staff
qui qui choisiront mais voilà c'est ça
peut être un point fort comme un point
très très faible pour lui ça aussi
déception
on va en faire qu'une parce que je suis
à la bourre je précise aux auditeurs on
avait promis deux checks mais refaire
une déception chacun une satisfaction
chacun allez à choisir entre les deux je
vais prendre philippovski qualifie
pivot en allemand de métier fort à Dieu
qu'un sevenfooter qui a joué il est
forte la saison olé ici et c'est
freshman donc voilà un grand adduke qui
qui fait des bonnes stats on connaît
il a comment dire il m'a déçu à
l'amortissement parce qu'il a pas
capitalisé sur sa taille c'est un joueur
qui a 7 pieds qui est défendu par des
mecs normalement bien plus petit que lui
et il a pas réussi à prendre cette
domination physique on sait que c'est
pas un gros athlète on sait que c'est un
joueur qui a Stockel avec son tir à
trois points toute l'année là il a fait
un masque dans la défaite à zéro sur 5 à
3 points je crois face à face à
Tennessee
il s'est fait dominer par Olivier
narcmoy donc j'ai pas de problème avec
le Finlandais à part prononcer son nom
de famille mais
qu'un mois c'est ça mais il lui a mis il
lui a mis la misère donc ouais déçu par
quel philipsy j'aurais aimé cette année
en fait qui joue pivot on en parlait en
streaming pas très longtemps j'aurais
aimé qui joue sur sa position pour voir
si oui ou non il peut le faire parce que
il jouera pas il est fort NBA il a pas
les capacités athletic dans la mobilité
notamment la mobilité latérale pour
pouvoir être un défenseur sur les postes
dédiés
et j'aurais aimé voir s'il pouvait être
un peu en protection de cercle s'il
pouvait prendre des rebonds contester ou
non s'il pouvait
utiliser ce Haendel qu'il a pu démontrer
du côté de Duke face à des joueurs
grands et du coup montrer que cette
puissance parce que même si c'est pas un
gros athlète je trouve assez puissant
assez fort pour tenir au contact et
garder ce move et garder son dribble
genre des joueurs plus grands donc voilà
une déception philippowski sur
sur l'année en général et ça c'est ma
nièce ou il devait être l'homme de cette
équipe pour aller loin et finalement il
a il a pas réussi à être
vingtième de notre big board puis le les
lier fort du coup de Duke flip of ski
manutent satisfaction de cette marche
maness c'est jazz Walker de Houston et
évidemment évidemment et là pour le coup
on est sur le numéro 7 de notre big
board et quand je ferai mon bord il va
monter parce que je vais clairement le
mettre numéro 3 ou 4
ou c'est là contrairement
à prouver tout ce qui s'est bien fait et
très bien faire et il sait même il a
même un peu Step Up et franchement
c'était assez incroyable il est post 4,5
de Houston un petit post hybride 4,5 qui
qui va devoir s'améliorer sur le pour
être vraiment plus plus plus plus
qui va devoir s'améliorer sur le tiers
extérieur qui qui se recule petit à
petit s'il était il commençait on
commence à le voir en High School ça ce
petit tir à trois points
qu'est-ce qui t'a plu alors sur la
Madness mais c'est aussi surtout sa
capacité à possiblement être en fait
aussi un rime Protector
il y a le
match contre au Burns je crois ou il
fait 5 ou 6 contre face à des gros
bavards c'est l'une des équipes les plus
physiques de la NCA donc ça a été
intéressant de le voir répondre à ce
niveau là en une scie on sait qu'il
avait le physique pour les contester
machin machin mais c'est un rime
protecteur qu'on n'avait pas trop trop
vu sur la saison
et qui a réussi à tes peuple là-dessus
et c'est vraiment ça que j'ai aimé et
que ça ça lui apporte encore quelque
chose en plus dans ce qu'il avait et ce
qu'il faisait déjà très bien sur la
saison à Houston où il était
moi je sais pour moi c'est un espèce
aussi de connecteur sans le sang dans le
sens où on l'entend de passe ou quoi il
est vraiment connecteur défensivement il
parle beaucoup il est vraiment actif
capable d'aller partout de défendre sur
le pivot comme sur la possession d'après
d'aller sur sur le porteur de balle
c'est voilà c'est il a montré une saison
incroyable
il a marché sur ça sur ces saisons High
School et franchement assez
impressionnant je pensais pas qu'il
allait être aussi fort à une scie
honnêtement j'aimais beaucoup avec Alan
on aimait beaucoup à IMJ mais il est
impressionnant
et faut quand même pas oublier de dire
que Houston c'était une des meilleures
équipes du pays que lui c'était un
fraichement une vraie fraîchement dans
l'année de ces 19 et que il a joué plus
de 25 minutes par match voir quasiment
30 minutes ça en fait vrai juste ce fait
là prouve qu'il est prêt pour être un
contributeur dès l'année prochaine en
NBA et ça c'est important quand même
pour la projection d'un joueur tu disais
la protection cercle c'est le ticket
c'est le ticket d'entrée en tout cas le
connecteur défensif Hugues ont terminé
avec toi pour ta
satisfaction parce que je veux rendre à
César ce qui est à César it's Miller
time
je suis allé chercher Jordan Miller le
mec qui a défoncé un diagouest Walker en
morte Madness donc c'est quand même bien
de le rappeler alors là on est sur un
profil vraiment très différent cinquième
année qui a pu profiter du covid entre
guillemets pour avoir une cinquième
année supplémentaire il a fait trois ans
à George Michael et là
transférer et la changer d'école l'an
dernier pour aller du côté de Miami le
Hurricane qui ont pas sorti du jour NBA
depuis notre ami comment il s'appelle
sur Dan walk dans Walker le New Walker
expérimentée avec alzher Wong avec Nigel
pack qui arrive
et Jordan Miller était la pardon
excusez-moi pour le son derrière était
la deuxième option c'est un évier à Metz
96 98 très avancé physiquement il a 5
ans de 150 facs dans les dans les jambes
puissant très bon finisseur gaucher
excellent rebondir pour la position et
pour et pour le poste
petit à trois points ça va être encore
une fois une chaîne d'entrée pour lui
pour avoir une chance de jouer dans la
grande ligue ce sera un joueur qui sera
au mieux second tour
player mais je pense que ce tournoi fait
qu'on a pu avoir de la visibilité sur ce
garçon moi je le sais pas un jour que je
suis les particulièrement et parce que
les 15 sont allés loin j'ai regardé j'ai
dit mais il est vraiment fort ce gars là
clutch décisif
toujours en défense sur le sur le
meilleur joueur adverse aussi capable de
défendre des deux des trois des quatre
et devra attirer un peu plus au niveau
supérieur là on est sur deux trois
tentatives par match pour de 32% pareil
au niveau des lancer francs mais voilà
dans le dans les Alliés switch on peut
les faire un pro quoi un joueur pro quoi
potentiel de pro prospect donc c'est la
définition merci merci à vous deux
désolé de recher la fin mes obligations
personnelles m'oblige mais
mais ça fait moins de 45 minutes et on
espère que vous avez appris des trucs
avec nous sur cette marche manette vous
pouvez allez voir notre big board pour
avoir une idée de comment sont classés
les prospects au-delà de Victor
homebanyamak et numéro 1 consensuel
sur sur notre bigboard donc sur
envergure.co pour cette draft 2023 cette
nous des retours mettez-nous des like
sur les applications d'écoute et puis on
vous retrouve très bientôt on va
commencer notre série justement de
portraits des des meilleurs prospects
des de cette draft 2023 merci Hugues des
bisous à tous et merci Manu plaisir
à bientôt tout le monde ciao ciao